let's react to TLC show Extreme
Cheapskates I don't really like the
title and some of these are actually
quite unhealthy but some actually make
some sense huge thanks to butcherbox for
sponsoring this video let's get started
I'm going to be making a lasagna by any
chance if you have any other ground beef
that's already left over it's all sold
we sell it on a daily basis fresh all
the time okay and so there's nothing
that would expire oh no
we don't sell expired product here you
don't want to sell expired beef because
expired beef will literally have
listeria E coli all sorts of bacterias
in it that can cause a really serious
colitis requiring IV antibiotics
requiring a hospital stay possibly a
surgery a collecting me work you're
cutting out pieces of your intestine
like you don't want that how much would
two pounds
the B fat B 2.53 cents man I will take
the beef so instead of using protein
she's just using the beef fat by
supplementing the meat with the beef fat
Stephanie saved 75 percent on the
ingredients for her lasagna but then
you're changing the nutritional makeup
of the food completely like when you go
to a store and you buy 80 ground beef
that means it's 80 percent lean and 20
fat here now you've changed the
proportions to be like the other way
like 20 protein and 80 fat that's that's
terribly unhealthy like probably the
unhealthiest thing you can do to the
food like red meat on its own already
has some troubles when you overeat it
and then you create heart disease this
is like quadrupling that problem now to
save money I multitask with washing
dishes and cooking meals with my dishes
I just got to make sure I wrap it really
well or else the food will get wet with
the dishwasher reaching a temperature of
170 degrees the lasagna will be fully
cooked in one a half hours no because
you don't know if the temperature is
like that all across unlike an oven
where it's controlled the pennies that
you're saving here will pale in
comparison to the one time that you get
sick and your hospital bills are out of
control that's what I'm trying to say
that it's not that I'm judging this
process it's just not a practical
process not a healthy process ideally
this should be changed it's good right
to be cooked in a dishwasher the lounge
taste like water yeah and the kid
rightfully said no if I had a patient
that was doing that I would seriously
discuss whether or not we can change
that and if the patient was not
receptive to it there may be a
conversation about getting some people
involved to go check on the welfare of
those children dumpster diving in the
trash of upscale grocery stores in New
York these stores often throw away a lot
of very high quality foods yeah I've
heard that putting organic foods and
really nice prepared foods and there's a
lot of these stores in New York that
have relationships with food banks so
that they don't make waste of this food
and they can feed our homeless
population New York just what they don't
want to have happen is constantly people
just waiting outside of their
restaurants because then it creates a
pattern where then it might demotivate
some individuals from actually going to
a shelter seeking Refuge getting the
proper help that they might need Etc I'm
guessing these Tomatoes got thrown out
probably because they're among a bunch
that had maybe one or two that were
spoiled so often the store would just
throw the whole batch out it's not like
bread when there's a piece of mold in
any part of the bread you got to throw
the whole thing out with tomatoes or
berries you could just get rid of the
ones that have mold on them there is a
chicken asparagus with two sides here my
friends might like this even though I
don't like chicken this is they did
today what is it these are some a
vegetables with a turkey and chicken
mashed potatoes
and this is a chicken fried rice so
everything's in the same pot it turned
yeah this is a medley I actually like
eating Foods in a medley and my friends
make fun of me of it they're like Mike
you're eating at a horse trough but I
like it that way that's why I get your
poly burrito bowls
[Music]
it didn't seem too fond of it but that
has nothing to do with her saving money
she's just not a good cook if my friends
came over and asked me to cook for them
they'd probably make the same face while
pulling expired sandwiches out of a
grocery store garbage bag might be
affordable I don't think you should ever
cut Corners when it comes to eating a
healthy and safe diet which is why for
the last year I've made sure to get so
many of my ingredients from butcher box
they deliver fresh certified organic
chicken wild caught seafood and
grass-fed beef right to my front door
this saves me so much time and gives me
peace of mind every month knowing that
I'm getting the highest Quality Meats I
don't have to get in my car drive to the
grocery store Park push around a
shopping cart and then lug everything
back home having the food brought right
to my doorstep just means I get to eat
sooner and easier recently I've been
enjoying their wild caught Alaskan
sockeye salmon which is not only
delicious but packed full of nutrients
it's seriously so good butcher box
practices thoughtful sourcing when it
comes to selecting their products too
which means that I can trust her high
quality food is better for me the
farmers the animals welfare and our
planet they're super flexible with what
you can get in your box too and if
you're looking for a more affordable
option their cheapest box actually has
enough food for 24 meals meaning you and
your family can have a home-cooked meal
five nights a week for an entire month
and then some you can choose your
delivery frequency too so you get
exactly the foods you and your family
love all in an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box not to mention shipping
is always free I think that's a pretty
good deal click the link below to claim
this month's exclusive limited time
offer for butcher box plus free shipping
when you use my link all right let's get
back to the show in the past six years
Mark has volunteered in more than 100
medical studies and the risk year the
trial the better it pays well actually
I'm not going to even say that this is a
bad thing because we need more
volunteers for our research new studies
that I'm waiting on that I have not been
in yet is a flatline study this is a
really good one what they do is they
stop your heart for one minute but you
still breathe stay there 14 days pays
twenty five thousand dollars but the FDA
kind of step in and stop that whoa you
flatlined for a minute and they keep you
breathing and then bring back your pulse
through epinephrine my God I don't I
can't even imagine the second one that
I'm really anxious and really excited
and waiting to do what you do is you go
in and you donate one of your testicles
they replace it with an artificial one
and when you check out after 14 days you
get a check for thirty five thousand
dollars that's an expensive testicle 35
000 per testicle I never knew that there
was a study that did that not all
studies are this dramatic a lot of them
are more for medications that are well
known well tolerated just kind of
comparing different patient populations
that's why I recommend everyone visit
clinicaltrials.gov to learn more Mark
participates in so many clinical trials
that he gets free checkups every month
to see if he's a good candidate for each
study so a checkup that's seeing if
you're a good candidate doesn't always
mean that you're getting a good checkup
a good preventive visit during a visit
you don't just get a checkup you also
get active risk assessment then advice
on those risks so this isn't a
replacement for a checkup so what I'd
like for you to do is take off your
shirt okay and I'll come back in and
we'll do a brief exam okay okay and also
I gotta check out your gyms okay so
let's take a look at that too see I like
that the doctor's laying out exactly
what's going to happen during the visit
before doing it because I see a lot of
young doctors and older doctors are like
rushing through these procedures not
getting the patient enough time to
mentally prepare to physically prepare
for what's going to happen whatever the
exam might be being a lab rat you have
to be very healthy your Labs have to be
in certain ranges and levels in a
healthy level to be a healthy control
when he says a healthy control that
means he's probably in the group that's
being held at a constant and not be
given the experimental treatment the
thing is with randomized controlled
studies which is the gold standard of
scientific evidence you want to be
blinding not just the researchers but
also the patience meaning not knowing
who's getting the true treatment and
who's in the control arm so in a
double-blind style study he wouldn't
know if he's in the control group or not
your heart sounds regular and I don't
hear extra beats so what we're listening
when we listen with the stethoscope to
the heart you want to make sure that the
the rate is consistent not too fast not
too slow it has to be a regular rate not
irregular that could be a sign of an
arrhythmia like afib is a common one
atrial flutter is another but then
you're also listening for the flow of
blood that's when we can detect
something known as a murmur which is how
blood flows through the different
chambers of the heart or different
arteries and when we hear certain sounds
that murmur depending on which location
we hear it where it it's most intense we
can then decide the area that we're most
concerned about it's like all these
things need to be taken into
consideration and then we could order
further testing like an echocardiogram
which is an ultrasound of the heart to
visualize exactly what we're going on
and usually if you're really good with
the stethoscope You can predict what
you're going to see on an EKG or a
necrocardiogram because it's a great
tool drop your drawers and we just kind
of you know examine both testicles we
rub them between our two fingers you
want to use more medical terminal
analogy rather than lay person
terminology because that can make people
feel uncomfortable when you're doing it
you also want to visualize the area so a
lot of the times I see on these shows
they're doing stuff like this like
they're almost looking up and not
looking at the region that they're
making contact with then you could miss
all sorts of rashes hair conditions
masses that you might see with your
vision not uh with your touch overall
it's an incomplete physical exam in my
eyes low testosterone levels affect
roughly 39 percent of men a low test
result for Mark would take him out of
the running for the testicular study the
risk to use is pretty significant I'm
not endorsing the surgery Mark's test
results are well below the acceptable
range set for the clinical trial when
you're seeing a primary care doctor like
myself and you're going in for a
pre-operative clearance we're not
deciding if the surgery is right for you
we're deciding your risk for the
procedure and if there's any way we can
optimize your medical state or your
health in order for you to have
decreased likelihood of adverse effects
from the surgery Maybe going on
testosterone replacement would be a
great thing for you okay have you ever
thought about doing that well how about
asking him if he has issues that could
show that his low testosterone is
clinically significant as opposed to
just asymptomatic lab finding like an
asymptomatic lab finding is not always
necessary to be treated especially men
of an older age like this is where you
got to be really careful with these
hormone replacement clinics and I'm not
saying anything specifically about this
one because this might not be showing
the whole visit but just in general to
keep it in your back of your mind while
it doesn't pay as much a statisticular
removal study Mark does manage to land a
spot in a trial testing testosterone
replacement each one of these pills
represents the me a car insurance
payment 75 every Monday cash fifty
dollars every Tuesday 125 a week times
four five hundred dollars a month equals
my rent and my car payment your rent and
your car payments 500 bucks that's very
reasonable one of the main things that I
look for when I go dumpster diving now
are our medication especially prenatal
vitamins okay very dangerous
specifically when it comes to
medications because a lot of times
medications are not in correct pill
bottles and may not be labeled correctly
and therefore you may not know their
expiration date or their dosage and that
presents a whole host of problems I
think expiration dates in general are
kind of
not sure what she means but but there is
some truth to the fact that a good
amount of the medications if stored
properly if stored properly if stored
properly could be good past their
expiration date for a short period of
time and the reason why I say that is
because there was actually a study done
by the government to see that the
medications that were stored in the
military bases they were stored in
correct locations with the correct
conditions five years after some of them
were still effective and the ones that
were expired past that time were just
less effective they kind of lost their
efficacy and you have to think as a
doctor when is that dangerous that's
dangerous if you're thinking about
taking expired emergency medications
like epinephrine insulin these are
medications that if they're not
effective you're in danger taking an
expired Tylenol the real risk of it is
that it might not work but taking
expired epinephrine when you're having
an anaphylactic attack means that you
can die you see how there's a difference
there A lot of times they put expiration
dates on things way earlier than they
need to just to sell more products
that's not the case it's done on in a
way that you need to understand common
use and when you think of common use
most people do not properly store their
medications they frequently store them
in the bathroom which is a high humidity
environment which is not good for any
medication medications that are like in
gels and in liquid form tend to be even
shorter expiration dates meaning they're
they're good for a shorter period of
time because they're more likely to go
bad
bingo
acid which is good for pregnancy I mean
folic acid is important for pregnancy
it's advised by the AFP and the CDC that
individuals who are considering getting
pregnant or are pregnant take 0.4
milligrams to 0.8 milligrams which is
400 micrograms to 800 micrograms of
folic acid as a way to decrease the
likelihood of neurologic defects
occurring during pregnancy every dollar
we spend on anything other than food is
a waste wow I don't see the need to
spend money on furniture I'm a floor guy
I sit on the floor and it's very
comfortable I mean to each their own
like this isn't a medical issue here
what I did was I found some two by fours
and these are Styrofoam peanuts so I
just take all the peanuts throw them in
there and then I cover it up with bubble
wrap and then this is a tablecloth and
it makes a perfect bet I mean I just
don't know if I would go to say perfect
bed I could see a lot of those like foam
peanuts move around and then as a result
you're laying on the hard floor and
putting pressure on your shoulder older
that you could wake up with quite the
painful rotator cuff or labor to find
good roadkill on the road and if it's
fresh fresh fresh and good I'm a butcher
I have no problem whatsoever eating
something that's fresh and good I mean
this person's a butcher so at least they
have some experience on whether or not
certain foods are safe to eat it doesn't
seem ideal given that it's not
controlled how these things die did a
car run over it did it eat some poison
then die then a car ran over you know
what I'm saying tonight we're serving
barbecued rabbit and a tossed salad made
with flowers that we've gathered I mean
you could just grow vegetables like you
can go to an apple tree Orchid and pull
an apple off of it and eat it and know
that it's an apple versus like I can't
even begin to guess the nutritional
facts on a dandelion it was weeds all
weeds dandelions flowers clovers things
that you just don't normally eat yeah
again I don't know the nutrition facts
of those things but it doesn't seem safe
or necessary that's the goal here wanted
a little thing a little discovery that
I've made a way to save on coffee I
enjoyed my coffee in the morning I have
two made my own little coffee device out
of an old sock
but you couldn't use a shirt you went
for the sock they definitely asked for
this on the show I hear the producers
are ready he's like I use a piece of
cloth they're like can you use a sock I
developed a method with rubber bands to
keep my soap levitated off of that water
it lets it dry it prevents mildew and my
soap last double the amount of time it
would normally last I'm with it another
one that I'm with I'm probably saving
between 80 and 100 a year just don't
soap alone I love it you know I think
green tea is a really good drink click
here to learn all about the potential
benefits of green tea and again huge
thank you to butcherbox for sponsoring
this video as always stay happy and
healthy